[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au château de
maisons bijou architectural de la ville
de maisons-laffitte
nous allons découvrir son histoire et
les événements culturels qui s'y cachent
mais avant cela voici le sommaire son
architecture a inspiré louis xiv pour le
château de versailles le château de
maisons est considéré comme l'un des
chefs-d'oeuvre du xviie siècle nous
parlerons de la programmation culturelle
avec l'administratrice du château
l'exposition d'art contemporain de paris
sculptures en l'île accueillera 11
artistes le 13 mai prochain à andrésy le
thème de cette 25e édition
l'envers du décor nous avons pu être
présent au montage d'une oeuvre et enfin
la nuit européenne des musées est de
retour pour une 18e édition samedi 14
mai une dizaine d'établissements
culturels yvelinois participe comme le
musée de la toile de jouy à jouy en
josas
[Musique]
je me trouve devant le château de maison
à maison laffitte il a été construit
entre 1640 et 1650 pour rené 2000 guèye
le surintendant et des finances de
l'époque virginie gadenne bonjour
bonjour vous êtes l'administratrice du
château alors on va parler tout d'abord
de cette architecture grandiose
ce château fut édifiée par françois
mansart il est considéré comme l'un des
chefs d'oeuvre du xviie siècle oui tout
à fait alors il faut savoir que françois
mansart était un architecte très connu
de l'époque et que le château de maisons
est un des rares ouvrages
conservés intacts de sa main donc déjà
deux points de vue c'est un ouvrage
unique ensuite françois mansart est un
des
porteurs de l' architecture classique à
la française alors on reconnaît ses
marques à différents signes c'est déjà
la façon d'animer les façades en
recourant à des ornements classique que
l'on trouve superposés les uns aux
autres c'est ensuite la verticalité de
cette architecture avec de grands toits
d'ardoisé et un motif très fort centrale
et puis la symétrie bien sûr qui
caractérise aussi l' architecture
classique alors vous allez peut-être me
raconter son histoire maintenant son
architecture aspirer louis xiv pour le
château de versailles et il est devenu
aussi en 1777 la propriété du comte
d'artois oui donc rené de longueuil qui
est le commanditaire de ce château était
proche
du roi il était parlementaire à la cour
et il a porté l'édification de ce
château et on sait que le petit neveu de
françois mansart à la fin du chantier
jules hardouin mansart qui n'est autre
que l'architecte de versailles étaient
présents
ensuite ce château est restée dans la
famille jusqu en 1777 puis il a été
acquis par le comte d'artois le comte
d'artois était également propriétaire du
château de saint germain et aimait
beaucoup la chasse et avait besoin d'un
château de réception de relais de chasse
c'est pourquoi il a acquis le château de
maisons tout au long du 19e siècle le
château et rester entre des mains
prestigieuses notamment le maréchal
lannes proche de napoléon et puis
ensuite le banquier jacques laffite qui
au moment de la restauration s'est porté
acquéreur de ce château était lui même
proche du pouvoir avec en étant proche
de louis philippe ensuite ce château a
été entre des mains privées et notamment
le dernier propriétaire privé avant
l'acquisition par l'état était le
peintre wilhem thilleman bromont donc
maintenant ce château un programme
diversifié on est ouvert toute l'année
mais que peut-on voir ces prochains mois
alors déjà ce château je tiens à
souligner est meublée donc le visiteur
peut participer à des découverte du
château et de son histoire qui vont
raconter l'histoire à travers les
siècles ensuite nous avons une
programmation
destinée aux familles notamment les
week-ends ou en famille on peut
participer à des jeux sous forme d'
enquête mais on va apprendre des choses
sur les décors du château et sur son
histoire nous sommes également ouverts
par exemple pour la fête des jardins les
4 et 5 juin gratuitement le public
pourra bénéficier de visites guidées des
jardins rénové et enfin je mentionne
aussi que le 14 juin nous organisons en
soirée une grande réunion pour recruter
des bénévoles qui participeront à un
grand spectacle participatif qui se
tiendra cet hiver au château de maisons
a en ce moment une exposition visible à
une exposition temporaire son nom à 1882
1 et et nordiques et vous nous l'avez
fait découvrir des repas des sorties
dans les rues de maisons laffitte mais
c'est surtout la peinture qui rythmaient
la vie quotidienne de willem thilleman
gros mai dernier propriétaire privé du
château de maisons d'origine allemande
peintre collectionneurs et grand
voyageur il décide en 1882 d'inviter
plusieurs amis d'entre eux finlandais au
château de maisons ils réaliseront
plusieurs oeuvres cette exposition
présente donc pour la première fois
depuis 140 ans des oeuvres qui ont été
peintes au château qu'ils sont conservés
en finlande dans différents musées et
collections privées finlandaise et qui
retrouve aujourd'hui des cimaises du
château présenté au premier étage du
château des peintures exécutées par
willem thilleman gros mais mais
également d'autres réalisées par ses
invités comme adolf von becker ou albert
edelfelt on découvre aussi quelques
objets provenant des collections privées
de l'ancien propriétaire du château de
maisons vous présentons
des grands tirages de photographies qui
ont été réalisées à la demande de gros
mais pendant cette académie artistique
il avait commandé un reportage
photographique un photographe assez
connu dans l'histoire de la photographie
française qui s'appelle louis amédée
mentent et nous retrouvons des grands
tirages dans différentes pièces du
château qui évoque la vie de ces grands
propriétaires et peintre cette oeuvre
peinte en 1882 par gunnar berntsen
représente une femme à l'oiseau bleu
l'intérêt est double je dirais d'une
part pour nous
on reconnaît des décors du château donc
on peut apercevoir cette jeune femme qui
posait en fait précisément dans
l'encadrement de cette porte qui ouvre
sur l'anti chambre dite des reculs on
peut à travers ce témoignage avoir une
idée relativement exactes aussi des
coloris qui était ce par exemple des
boiseries du château à cette époque là
samedi 14 et dimanche 15 mai une
reconstitution de cette époque se
tiendra dans le château de maison et son
jardin dans le cadre de l'exposition des
visites chanter auront lieu aussi le 13
mai et le 3 juin prochain
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
virginie gadenne dans les jardins de
maisons alors vous nous l'avez un petit
feu ces jardins ont été rénovés l'année
dernière un césar oui alors nous avons
profité de toute la période du
confinement pour porter un grand
programme de rénovation des jardins du
château que savoir que le château a été
amputé malheureusement d'une grande
partie de ses jardins au 19e siècle et
donc là nous avons souhaité leur donner
une dimension vraiment d'écrin végétales
et puis permettre une promenade qui est
un certain faste pour les visiteurs nous
avons travaillé avec le paysagiste
benech qui est aussi qui a été aussi par
exemple architectes paysagistes des
tuileries et il ya eu à la fois un
travail pour replanter de nombreux
arbres il ya plus d'une centaine
d'arbres qui m'étais planté ainsi que
redonner à voir les grands axes
historiques fondateur de ce château
alors le château de maisons ainsi aider
celles de nombreuses anecdotes qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez m'en citer une par
exemple on peut parler des tournages qui
régulièrement se déroule au château de
maisons j'ai en tête un tournage
historiques comme celui de vatel ou des
liaisons dangereuses mais aussi des
tournages plus récents notamment la
série consacrée à louis xiv qui a connu
beaucoup de succès et dont une grande
partie des scènes a été tourné au
château de maisons et dans son dans sa
grande salle de réception merci beaucoup
virginie gavel damart et et d'autres
invités merci à vous
le 13 mai prochain marqué le début de
sculptures en l'île l'exposition d'art
contemporain de paris accueillera 11
artistes à andrésy le thème de cette 25e
édition l'envers du décor nous avons
assisté au montage dilf l'été bol une
oeuvre de laurent perbos ce invité
d'honneur fait d'aller à quelques jours
du lancement de sculptures en l'île pour
sa 25e édition l'exposition d'art
contemporain de paris à andrésy
accueille onze artistes sur le thème de
l'envers du décor des oeuvres installées
dans le parc de l'hôtel de ville et
surtout sur l'île nancy en une fois les
visiteurs vont pouvoir découvrir des
oeuvres d'art contemporain ils vont
prendre le bateau gratuitement et ils
vont visiter une île sauvage
dans les yvelines parmi les artistes
laurent perbos s'invitait d'honneur
l'artiste plasticien utilise l'objet
issus de la grande consommation comme
matière pour ses oeuvres comme ses
prédécesseurs il a été invité à habiller
la façade de la maison du moussel
d'andrésy inph la table c'est une oeuvre
in situ réalisés sur place spécialement
pour le bâtiment elle a nécessité près
de quatre jours d'installation et 150
gonflable de tailles diverses je vais
essayer de donner l'illusion que le
le bâtiment l'édifice est entièrement
rempli de gonflables et qu' il ya une
telle profusion que deux des fenêtres et
gonflable s'en échappe une oeuvre qui
propose deux lectures évocatrice de la
plage mais aussi critiqué d'une société
de surconsommation objectif questionner
le regard du spectateur pour premier
abord bass et gh et ludique coloré
joyeux et en fait finalement si on
regarde de plus près c'est aussi très
polluants ces issues d'une industrie
pétrochimique avec un indice carbone
très élevé enfin bref voilà tout le tout
l'envers du propos que c'est censé au
premier abord véhiculer cette année les
visiteurs pourront suivre l'exposition
via une application numérique
l'application s'appelle à ce que naïs
c'est l'intelligence artificielle et
c'est une une application que les
visiteurs pourront mettre sur leur
téléphone pour suivre
pédagogiquement et ludiquement le
parcours et donc les oeuvres d'art
sculptures en l'île débutera le 13 mai
prochain les oeuvres seront à découvrir
jusqu'au 25 septembre
dans les yvelines des événements sont
également à prévoir dans vos agendas les
prochaines semaines et on commence avec
un rendez vous artistique du 18 mai au
1er juin le salon à des arts de montigny
le bretonneux est de retour pour une 31e
édition des oeuvres de styles et de
techniques différents ils seront exposés
au conservatoire des armes photographe
unis ni montant un clos de linges et
sera invité d'honneur
samedi 21 mai aura lieu le premier
festival du livre de sartrouville
organisé par la librairie des gens qui
lisent de 16h à 21h 22h sur meu présents
sur la place de la gare au programme
dédicaces rencontres ateliers ou encore
spectacle et on termine en musique
isabelle lesire ligne sera sur la scène
du théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jeudi 19 mai à 19h30 et vendredi 20 mai
à 20h30 l'artiste suédoise présentera
son deuxième album intitulé amar est un
mélange de folklore scandinave du
musique traditionnelle africaine avec
nos craintes dé l'écran
[Musique]
la nuit européenne des musées revient
pour une 18e édition samedi 14 mai une
dizaine d'établissements y participent
comme le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines le musée maurice
denis ou encore la maison léon blum de
19h à 22h le musée de la toile de jouy
il sera également ouvert au public on
écoute la maire adjointe déléguée à la
culture à jouy en josas nous avons
choisi deux dédié une animation au jeune
public
sur le parvis du musée jusqu'à l'entrée
du juste à l'entrée de
du château de l'églantine que nous avons
vu son ensemble tout à l'heure avec
ses jolis jardins qui s'inspire des
appels les toiles imprimées qui sécher
au soleil du temps de la manufacture de
marque ans juste à côté les enfants vont
pouvoir réaliser à la craie des motifs
de toiles de juillet en s'inspirant de
motifs qui ont leur proposera en en othe
médiatrice qui va animer les ateliers
donc ce sera de 19 heures à 22 heures
parallèlement à la possibilité de
visiter le musée
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous au la
semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yves binois bonne soirée sur
tv5 ici
[Musique]